but when I heard that
after I just used to stand up and
holding the knife in my hand
then I just shouted with this man if you
touched my son I want to kill you
[Music]
Jihan thanks so much for joining us it's
fantastic to have you here before we get
into it can I just ask you in your own
words to introduce yourself
I was born in North Korea and I escaped
North Korea twice so now I am human
rights activities in the UK so today I
want to share about the North Korea
human rights issues to audience
fantastic and I think the thing that's
striking about your story is escaping
North Korea not once but twice
um
what stands out to me as interesting in
the first place is that North Korea is
famously a very controlled place and
somewhere where there's a there's a
degree of brainwashing that goes on from
a young age
so how do you get to a point where
you've been raised in a place that is
brainwashing you what triggers wanting
to escape did you always know that you
didn't like it and that something was
wrong or was there a specific event that
made you think
there's a different life outside this
I didn't know much about outside the
countries because North Korea they will
bring the outside information into North
Korea so still the North Korea same and
you know that they have got to own only
one TV channels and only one newspaper
so that is describing the only guimir
song Kim Jong-il and nowadays Kim
jong-un's issues not say it's a daily
life you know the example is a UK's food
crisis and you know Supermarket put is
limited or something is a human's issues
so were you aware of the outside world
or do they completely limit any
information or do they publish
propaganda and do they say it's
dangerous and frightening and we
shouldn't go out to there oh yeah North
Korea always said that North Korea's
socialism Country and this country is
best country not only socialism
countries is all about the world is best
countries because the reasons Kimberly
song is present and the gameration is
called yeah and we only this until the
1980s you know we only saw that is some
socialism countries another day visited
North Korea leaders visited North Korea
and they celebrated the Kimmel songs
birthday something that
but after is it started in 1990s it's a
limited they not published a lot of news
it's you know the North Korea when I was
born and the post-education was human
hate ideology
so we hated South Koreans Americans we
didn't know the particip government said
that and we also hated anti-socialism
person anti-socialism countries so that
is opposed to my educations when I was
born so that's why we played all this is
World Games with my friends so that is
growing of brain worship brain worship
and we believed always what government
said that and the day also said to us
South Korea is America America Colony
and you know the people still the hunger
and they homeless and America's
capitalism country so capitalism is
really bad because it's also same thing
is that they have not put and homeless
people and every street people is
sleeping on the street
so we believed that yeah you believe
that because we didn't get any
informations
but in started in 1990s government
stopped our put because it's North Korea
is still the day
another I said uh put this to the
Persian country there's only one country
in our world you know but early 1990s
they stopped our rise and then they said
to us it is America problems because we
wanted to buy food in outside the
country but America sounds used to us so
now we have a short put but everyone is
continued to fight
so that is all happened our lifetimes
not only early 1990s but that is a worse
Wars under 10 people died of starvation
and we saw many dead bodies in Street
you know train stations and every day we
woke up we heard that which neighbors
died of salvations and the families
separated each other so I couldn't
believe that it is what age were you
here sorry this time is I was 25 26
years yeah and I was a high school
teacher
so when I went to the school and you
know my children didn't go they arrived
in school classroom and children didn't
listen to us they just lie down in on
table and also room is really quiet then
we heard that they stomach is it sounds
it was a really hard time but
I also kind of another is a printable
adult to my children's so I continue to
push it to them why you didn't listen to
me why you didn't bring your homework
but not only to that after school they
also is a kind of the first level walk
in um but it's it's a farmer's side or
mountains the cleaning the road Street
the children yes yeah it is happening
North Korea is still the happenings so
the children were coming to school and
they were unable to concentrate because
they were so hungry but then they'd
finish school and be sent to forced
labor in different kind of manual places
yeah it's it's a still to happen in
North Korea what was the turning point
for you to decide to escape so my
turning point was is that the 1996 you
know that my uncle died of starvation in
front of me oh my God yeah but that's
times I didn't change my mind because
still the brain was still still believed
that is government
but in 1997 is my younger brother had
problems so last time he was joined is
an army and then you know the he also
kind of a business walk is a made money
to government but once the business was
failed because all countries collapsed
down so where is the money come from so
their business was closed down but this
is a really political issues because
they didn't pay the money to government
so after they do this run out it's all
groupies run out then he came to my
house but after his army they came to my
house on the day to just find out my
younger brother so because he couldn't
pay yes yeah take him for something yes
yes did you know what they would do to
him does his political problems you know
could be the arrested and then send the
political operations so that's why they
could members all run out right but so
he came to home and he didn't stay at
home and he sleep slept in they planned
the house but North Korea system is you
know the kind of 1984 it's everyone is
an eye on who is a state
someone's house or something that so
Army came to my home and the day people
is my home areas telling to them if you
watched my younger brother and contacted
to us so all neighbors all apartment is
you know the old towns look after my
house and also they looked after they
planned house too my God so basically
everybody around you was now looking for
your brother to report him to the army
yes yes and you just said that I think a
prender house I just what do you mean by
that sorry is it the school print house
yeah you know that people you know not
take finish the high school and then
started the armies 10 years oh yes I see
so he okay right so he basically ran
away so was it that was that the point
that you okay that's interesting because
I thought you decided that North Korea
the way of life wasn't correct but
actually was it more serious because you
were worried that your brother was going
to be captured by the Army and that's
what made you decide to leave you
decided because your brother was in
danger for political reasons that you
and your brother should Escape no that's
times I didn't I didn't doubt about it
so my brother is a once arrested another
in be denied he said somebody is a
doctor our house and then I opened the
door I was shocking because they
arrested my younger brother then already
beaten to him
so he all bought his swollen and his
evidence blood and then they came to my
house until the beaten
the early morning
so we have got two rooms so they beaten
is another room and me and my father
they did it in your house yes
we heard everything we heard everything
that's on the early morning I think that
was 5 00 am they opened the door
and I was
unspeakable unspeakable it's a you know
the already beaten to him but of and
then in my home they beaten to him his
four hours
four hours yeah and how old was he at
that point last time my younger brother
was 22. that time was 10. and so a group
of grown men yes yeah they all grown man
they baby 30 or 35 or something that's
so they blocked his you know the old
sticks so beaten to him okay and then
early morning they left my house because
they arrested my younger brother and
left to home
so then me and my father
didn't chat any words we knew that is
what's happened to my younger brother
and we knew that
we didn't see my younger brother
in future
so I think my father is copy cried
himself but he didn't say any words for
me
but two days after you know when my
younger brother left to home and then
two days after he came home again
he escaped again he has a chances
escaped or died
so it's a pivot you know yeah so he came
to home again and then my father told me
that leave this country
save your younger brother
that's times my father was an illness
and he couldn't move
so in 1998 his 18th February you know I
left North Korea with my younger brother
and then I abandoned my illest father a
learning called dining room
because my father condition was still
worse Wars so I couldn't wait my
father's pathway because my younger
brother is still the dangerous way
so that's his turning point is my father
my brother pushed to us
leave this country but I didn't know
that what happened in my next chapter
and I didn't know there's a China
information I didn't get any information
just only left North Korea so how did
you know what to do so that's time so
you know the we only knew that is the
China and North Korea border right that
is a two more Endeavor in North hanjong
Province uh this one is why I knew that
because I was a student we used the
first level in work year so turning the
13 you know to we left home and we
stayed another his Farmer's side it's
the spring is a party or 45 days in the
farmer is a farmer walks it's a first
level yeah and also Autumn is only 15
days so we knew that this place is based
China and so you've done that kind of
manual labor at a young age so you knew
where the board was to China yeah that
makes sense because I was going to say
why did you not choose South Korea for
example because obviously it's it's that
is really dangerous you know South Korea
is South Dakota as it could be I live in
North under South Korea is a part but we
North Korea is that we not troubles
freely we need a travel Document right
yeah so when we visited the grammar
house in Holiday times and we also
permission school first and then we get
to travel Document the other to get the
travel Document if you don't get the
travel Document you are not is
even just to move around in North Korea
not even to go anywhere just North Korea
wow today I come from Manchester to
London but but I didn't get any
permissions no I don't have any trouble
document but North Koreans always get
the trouble oh wow yeah it's still to
happen so they have no it's a free
movement yeah North Korea so in 1990
it's when it's stopped to rise and then
electricity is gone so after his many's
car is a kind of trouble it's a is
issues so we call it these guys service
car
so we paid to them cigarette or our core
and then they put towards some areas
so so is this how you got to the Border
you called the service car yeah paid
them in secret and they drove you to the
Border because they must have known what
you were going to do yes yeah we know
but it's quite dangerous for you because
if they then reported you yeah that is
a Dev and Then star beings so a lot of
service Cars come out because people
change it you know the uh close to the
port is some areas it's a lot of kind of
business happening in North Korea so me
and my younger brother separated
Journeys because it's my younger brother
is always a hide you know hide his work
in their ways or sometimes catch is the
trains but me is the difference is a
service car but when we cross the border
areas they have got to one is a army
places so this place is checked everyone
um so sometimes everyone is you know
there is a trouble to submit something
so I also talked to them is I want to
change it is
I have got some it's a piece in in my
back so my journey is took three days
and then you know that I arrived in
about the areas 21st and then my younger
brother arrived to 22nd wow okay so tell
us about crossing the border into China
were you scared
um of course it's scared and the first
time was
no
how we cross the border and we haven't
got any Brokers just only me and the
young my younger brother I was a broker
when you say Brokers that's something
that people do they pay a broker to get
you across the border yes yeah but you
guys were just you two just on you and
nothing just a big Outdoors yeah just
nothing but you know I just only
believed my younger brother because he's
a strong and he also already joined the
army so it was a February you know the
North and the time is really cold and
the liver is already present so it's a
tumor neighbor is not his long part some
areas only two meters or short is one
meters you know this is North Korea and
one meter is a Riverside under than
China wow yeah it's really close it's
our yellow level is is participated
meter or something that but device not
Automotive far is from North Korea to
China
so in 2 am we cross the border but you
know the rain we cross the halfway and
then North Korean soldiers find out to
us and then they shout and also gone
fired for us so they were trying to
shoot you yes yeah so at that point when
you say it was very cold and Frozen were
you wading in the river or were you
walking on the frozen ice to get across
yeah it just needs to walk here wow so
you're walking on the slippery slidy ice
and they're firing at you from behind
you yeah God that must have been that is
not to owning me all North Koreans yeah
they do that so I think it's a winter
across the border it was lucky because
it's ice but summer times you know
there's a water and sometimes you know
the lots of blood is come out but we
didn't assuming yes so do they try to
chase you and catch you across the
border or once you're crossed can they
not follow you yeah they not swallow
because if we already did
but my younger brother holding my hand
sister wake up wake up
yeah
and then after we already arrived in
China and then this ISO Isis slide is
melt and then I just all bodies in
inside the water
it's God so it must have been freezing
yeah can't believe it's all bodies
pretty
I I can't it's explained how that times
I felt so you you fell through the The
Ice into the freezing water but now
you're over into China but I assume this
is a very rural Countryside area that
you've arrived in
um you know but it's a Thailand North
Korea is a different you know the event
is a Riverside is North Korea also many
people lived in Riverside yeah Chinese
too oh so when you got there there was
houses and places oh wow so so what so
what did you do like were the people
there immediately or no we arrived in
there and after I found out that is one
house they light is on
knock the door and then this man is this
is often to know and when on the way
into today so this man told to us he
already heard this gunfire yeah so he
talked about or somebody's across the
border so in order how many people cross
the border to China
yeah I can't believe that is it a lot
lots a lot because of starvings yeah you
know the family members are stabbing so
many people cross the border and they
need some rice so the man whose door you
knocked on who lives on the border was
he used to seeing North Koreans Crossing
quite frequently so he he wasn't so
shocked it's something he's seen lots of
times yeah yeah
I was shocked of course yeah he never
shocked and then he gave it to us it's
nice mirrors you know white rice and the
meat and the eggs
it was Paradise you know yeah I didn't
know the next the chapters could be my
life is here but I never talked about
the next just only this moment was
Paradise yeah because in North Korea
white rice meanings only supposed to we
eat every year wow so just plain white
rice was a luxury
is you know the wow give me a song dream
was that one day my country people eat
white rice but he did made his Dreams
yeah so North Korea is white rice Is Our
Big Dreams
God so so you'd got to this man's house
and he gave you an amazing meal uh
that's a nice thing to do was he helpful
did he help you oh I don't know that is
really nice when I first met the Chinese
accordions first time was really nice
and could you communicate because it's a
you know the laptop but Chinese Korean
people in lives in the older right yeah
in Chinese for the areas so he could
speak your language yes yes yeah
but you know that I never talked about
the Chinese language or something that
never talked about that it's just only
I knew only Korean language so that's
why under here also Koreans so first
time was really nice but after we finish
it these mirrors and then he told me
that this is not to save places because
already come fires are happening in
North Korea so could be is a China it's
a police research in these areas and
what what happens in the case that
Chinese police find escaping North
Koreans what do they do they send back
towards North Korea what just pushed
make them walk back across the border oh
no they put the person in prison and
then sent back to North Korea because
China is joined is a United Nations
Refugee is used in 1984 but North Korea
and China they made another agreement
because two is above is communism
countries you know so they made that is
if someone is across the border we are
not accepted to them the refugees send
back to them because they are all
illegal people and then if China does
send the North Korean refugees back to
North Korea what will happen to them in
North Korea and then we stayed in place
we sent we decent to us about presence
could be executions and or political
presence okay okay so you understand now
that the place that you are in China is
very dangerous even though you've had
this meal that was amazing
what had to happen next so then he told
me that his friend is in City town is it
because that is a Truman River so too
many areas so I contacted to him
so I believed to him because he gave to
us you know the white rice nice meals I
believe to him but his friend is human
traffickers oh God okay yeah so it could
be he works with his friends too because
this selling the tours and under lots of
money so do you think they sold he sold
you and your brother to his friend oh
yeah I didn't know so once the he
planned to come to the this house and
then we moved to his house and after he
told me that you married Chinese man
you must marry a child yes yeah so I
first times I denied it to him I didn't
marry it I want to only save my younger
brother but I don't care any works
housekeep for restaurants yeah any work
I wanted to yeah
but he angered me he angry to me and
then he says that I maybe contacted you
a Chinese police then you both sent back
to North Korea so basically your choice
was
you do what he says which is be forced
to marry a Chinese man or he'll send you
back to North Korea where you know you
might be executed yeah okay so that is
really scared for me you know North
Korea
who somebody left these countries which
is anti-socialism so they have to kill
it to us understand the political
presence and you know my younger
brothers already tendered in North Korea
and by far the last division was to save
my younger brother
so that's why I abandoned my eldest
father yeah and when he was saying that
you would be sold
uh into marriage what would happen to
your brother so first time he said that
I talked about that if I
married a Chinese man he could be saved
my younger brother too he because
I believe the all people that yeah
but that is not happened you know the
Chinese man told me that I bowed to you
only you I live about your brother oh so
where was your brother at this point
yeah so then my younger brother told me
that sister you have to go you have to
save somewhere
to survive somewhere
so we separated each other's
then after I heard that my younger
brother also sent back to North Korea
oh God
so I still don't know that
my younger brother is Survivor or not
but my hope is never give up
so that was the last time you saw your
younger brother yes when you separated
so still my younger brother ages 22.
in my head
yeah and it's
it's so sad that your father's wish was
for you two to escape but especially to
save the brother and then of course he
was sent sent back to to Korea
um
and your
you had been taken by the person who had
bought you who then trafficked you and
sold you
to somebody that would be your husband
is that correct
um I I don't say that he's a husband
because he's you know that of course
yeah when I arrived his house I was
shocking because his house is almost the
collapsed on you know and also toilet is
outside his toilet was almost the clubs
down and this smells came to the hall
inside the home okay and its Pro is
really dirty
oh my God I can't believe that it's
North Korean people is really clean you
know yeah and they also clean the house
every day but house was oh my God I I
never see this kind of houses in my life
so had he had he what was he a farmer
yes yes yeah he's a farmer yeah so was
it a Countryside rural area again yeah
yeah it's contrary and had he had he
bought you because he wanted you to tidy
his house and keep it clean and was it
just one female which was you or was
there lots of ladies or how did it work
when I arrived to his house and then I
met his mother so his mother told me
that I spoke to you and you know I
borrowed a lot of money so you can walk
outside then paid back pay this morning
the first time is I didn't understand
what you mean that because
you know the broker broker told me that
I married this year but this mother told
me that I broke to you right so I was a
Computing the first time and then next
day I understood you know that I arrived
his house is 10 pm it's a late night but
the early morning is 4 AM is mother told
me that wake up wake up YouTube is work
outside
wow so you'd been bought as kind of like
slave labor bases yes yes
on you know it's all North Korean
females kind of sex slavery and also
celebrity drivers in in China
oh God it's awful awful so first times I
couldn't believe and then early
disappoint is I don't know how can I
describe this world but then
another females North Korean females
they also kind of human trafficking
disability
so that's times on five females in there
but we couldn't
uh communication each others right
because all is the neighbors and the
towns they look after to us it's a
similar North Korean system I see and
and did everybody know that you were
North Korean so was it illegal for you
to be there so that the farmer should
have sent you back to North Korea that
is illegal yeah it's illegal so that's
why every day they is brainwashed to us
right now because they could get in
trouble yes you escaped the discount you
know we this is maybe arrested to you
and we killed you or we live to you
right but nobody know about that or we
send to your uh China police stations
and send back to North Korea they
another brain was it to us God the thing
that's so sad to hear about listening to
this is you escape from North Korea into
almost a worse situation it sounds awful
like that you've been basically you'd
Escape somewhere that you thought was
going to be
safe and then you've got immediately
human trafficked yeah this is you know
the only
hours Paradise for me you know that is
Mia
that is only
with my younger brother yeah then then
after
it's kind of still this is a celebrity
life and you know the every morning is
the neighbors is told to us are you
still hungry
you know and then you know that they
bring some vegetables do you need this
one do you eat or something nuts it's
discrimination smart Lots I was really
angry to that because you know the when
I arrived at this Village and then some
Chinese Koreans they really like
education and they didn't know that is a
Chinese characters or something that but
I knew
I knew it's better than to them I knew
more more is the Chinese characters you
know so I didn't speak English but I
understand today to see the characters
so which is what kind of a shop or
something that but today's
discriminations for me so they saw you
with a kind of lower class citizen or on
it so what was the the General Life on
the farm from what it sounds like you're
describing was just non-stop work is
that correct yeah no Starbucks it's
started Springs in the farmer side they
started growing up with you know the
lots of things so we early morning work
is 5 00 am and until the dark days
always this work and you know the ones
it's a really whole today's so it's a
lunchtime people is stopped work it's
really hot so when I came to home and
you know that is a model is alone it's a
luncheon
oh but when I came to home she hide
everything and then gave to me only rice
and kimchi
yes unbelievable they never accept me
the family members they all need look
like me so slavery workers or sex
celebrities
yeah and and when you say there about
that there's obviously this next topic
is very dark and unpleasant and if
there's any questions that you don't
want to answer it's fine but when you
mention sex slavery I'm am I correct in
thinking that you you became pregnant
didn't you during this time
so you know that first time is I wanted
to give up my life
I lost my younger brother
and I abandoned my father
so
lost to all families and then China is
life was hell it's kind of another hair
how could I survive but after I found
out that I was pregnant
but the first times I really angry for
me you know the if this child born in
China could be his child also same life
for me it's a celebrity life
but after I want to change my mind
this child this could be my last family
and this child could be
giving me another hope and opportunity
so then
I changed my mind
but China is the same is the system is
in North Korea they never allowed as a
foreign it's a child in birth to China
so I was illegal and I was North Korean
so one day it's a village they have got
a female captains it's the same same as
system in North Korea she came to me and
she told me that your you to this
abortions this child because we never
accept your child so she told you you
had to
so I say that's no
then you know the eyewear is a bit close
because nobody find out me and and I
never gave up my work early morning
until the dark days even when you were
heavily pregnant yeah yes did the farmer
the father of the child and his mother
did they know you were pregnant yeah
they know but they never care about me
okay you know the people I didn't walk
outside they didn't give me rice and
relatives so even though you were
pregnant yes yeah and also then not to
give to me any proper shoes
I always wear the slipper oh my God
because in case I expected right yeah
okay so in winter you know the winter is
the North China is a lot of snow but I
wear the slipper because they never gave
to me any proper it's a juice under any
proper clothes it's always a second-hand
clothes or something that yeah
when you look back on that and think
about them because when you tell me the
story it sounds so cruel their treatment
of you sounds so cruel do you how do you
think about that now like do you think
they just saw you as
a less valuable human how could they
possibly treat someone so badly but in
North Korea also I was not human you
know kind of prisoners brilliant worship
child is Art life so in China it's the
same thing but only they have got rice
that is only different but this rise is
not free I always walk outside yeah but
now people I didn't pregnant could be I
want to Suicide person but the the sense
of having something to live for gave you
another lease of life
and then I mean I how on Earth did you
give birth in that situation
in China you know I was illegal you know
that so I never
went to the hospital I never you know
the kind of accident I never get any
medicines yeah so I always hide my as a
fragrant until the my child's divorce so
my child was born in 20th March but last
time the stared called in China
so you know that it's the first days
I was the it's a stomach ache but first
times I didn't know that is the started
is the child boss but that is the egg is
long long time so then I just remembered
or does it could be my child's form but
nobody helped me
I only myself is 12 hours is my level
wow
she never care about me it's the it's
worse
so it's terrible hours and then you know
the after that is in village is old lady
the China and North Korea still The
Neighbors in at home so kind of with the
is what said is a female so they helped
that so it's old lady
she came to my house because she heard
that is started yeah so she helped me
she helped me but
is the first time and I did not have
this pains and I miss my mother I really
miss my mother
But after when my child was born and
then I holding hand him
that was another happiness moment
because I have family now
um yeah I mean it's it sounds like
almost an impossible amount to take in
for a young a young girl
um
how how did you then
how did you live because it now
presumably you couldn't just walk work
every day in the way that you had
worked before because you have a young
baby that needs to be taken care of but
the seven days after I continued walked
because nobody gave it to me any lies
anybody tips
and do you know there is a when I first
my child and it usually is it in Asians
when first child after we drink kind of
see soup for sweet soup but
their families never gave to me any
anything so it was just straight back to
work yes yeah so last time it's been my
son was born and I gave to him his name
that is iron
strong life in China
so family members they don't like that
but that is my child not today child
that's my child
so I always work with my child so you're
carrying the child while you're yes back
to my child as a young baby wow I
continue to work because it's this
Chinese man is you know the it's a
hardcore addict and it's a gay medic so
he didn't walk outside so that's why the
family members hate me they hate their
son unders hate me is it though that is
it could be my son was born three months
after his 100 days and then one night he
just is a drink lots of drink and came
to my house the farmer yeah farmer is so
strong yeah and then he said that I want
to sold it to my son because he Daft
lots of gamblings money to another
person so that's times you know the time
is still the similar North Korea system
and
as many people they need a child is
especially boy yeah yeah so it's my son
is that time is a daily healthy boy you
know so many people they need that but
when I heard that
after I just used to stand up and
holding the knife in my hand
then I just shouted to this man if you
touched my son I want to kill you that
is the first time I fight to evil in
front of me
that is the first time
so then I never my son is alone in this
room I'll always with him walk outside
because I would already scared
and it I'm aware at some point that you
left the farm
um when my son was born and then one
years after it's you know the my Village
is five North Korean females stayed
there so before the new year is a
Chinese police came to this Village and
they arrested all five females including
you yes including me and including my
child
so I was really scared and not only
missed all is female scared so they
could be sent back towards North Korea
so we first stayed in the Chinese police
stations two days almost three days
but really scared moment is my child is
just not one years old now and we have
about any is the nothing so do not so I
just always wash off his uh the napkins
everywhere
they didn't say any any words so after
his police told me that
if you send back to North Korea is you
couldn't the with your child so you have
to solve this child and then pay to us
so it could be I didn't understand about
North Korea
but you have to sell the child to bribe
the police to stay in China then this
money is paid to police the police and
then they didn't send back to North
Korea
unbelievable unbelievable because they
are also a human they also somebody is
fathers yeah but this my child he's not
his products he's a human but they never
accept them I really angry to that but
they didn't send back to North Korea to
us okay because they need money
so after they put the towards is a house
and then locked the door so pay the 5
000 villains vians every house
so it's a I think it's seven days a day
this is a state in every houses they
just look after to us then they went to
the home because it started the new year
so so next day because the new eight
days the train is not working so next
day
I accepted this village with my child
and but you know I didn't know that any
person in China I only knew that is
female tropicals
so I had no choice
so I went to his house
the farmer yeah none of farmers also
human traffickers
he was the only person that you knew
yeah I only knew that oh my God
but I I wanted to survive with my child
so I wanted to his house and then I just
explained everything what happened in my
Village so I just is a big to him you
just lent me some house and then I
wanted to everything I want to save my
because I want to responsibility my
child so then he said that in in China
if you land house somebody gets a Dr ID
card but I haven't got an ID card so he
contacted again this farmer
so he came to me again he joined me
this is still the horrible still to talk
talkness life is happening but
I have no choice because my child yeah
my child so you know they invested left
Village and I stayed another places and
I do I did everything you know the maid
is a Korean dishes in our home and
growing up beings you know the Sprite
and The Salted outside and also you know
I was a teacher in North Korea so mass
Science is a good continue to good so I
this is a kind of illegal academics in
night times it's the Chinese Korean
student
so I took this on the money but I never
get money in my hand because this money
is always taken out this money and then
use the gambling scramblings so you're
you're basically back into the so how
was it that you ended up being arrested
and sent back to North Korea so in China
it's a same as North Korea systems you
know the every Chinese people
look it's around who is North Koreans or
something that's so they reported to us
so why do they do it do they get money
yes yes it's a government always this is
government paid money so that's why in
China you know lots of human traffickers
and a lot of that they said uh kind of
this spice because North Koreans selling
the human trafficking they earned money
or report to police and they also on the
money yeah so this morning everybody is
a high high high okay and the elite
people could be high prices yes so you
know the last year is one North Korean
uh so he stayed in Chinese prison but he
escaped his imprison after the surprise
is high high I see I see so it's like on
America when they have The Wanted list
it's that people can earn a lot of money
by yeah okay okay so then so that you
eventually were caught by people spying
on you and Reporting you is that correct
yes yeah they uh reported to me Chinese
police so night time is you know the 10
Chinese authorities came to my house and
they asked me in front of my child
did they take your child too
just asked me that you uh North Korea
video you're tired or without their
child because he's not spawning in North
Korea so I said that without my child
because it's been terrible because I
knew that is if with my child North
Korea and they will accept my my child
because he's born in China and the
father is a Chinese so you left the
child with the Chinese farmer yeah I
left him because it's a China is better
than in North Korea they have authorized
so it could be better than North Korea
life I know that is I was heartbreaking
but mother had no choice and how old was
a child at this point that time is my
son only five
okay
that must have been an impossible
decision yes yeah under I didn't know
the copy I want to reunited myself yeah
yeah I didn't know so you were taken
back to North Korea and then were you
imprisoned yes yeah it's everyone is a
state in prison everyone stayed present
and then they just is a divided who is
the met the South Korean uh is the
pastor in China is they sent to the
political prisons and who is the journey
you know the South Korea Journeys but
they failed and they
State political prisons so they
basically check they have a system of
how bad your crime is based on where you
went to or what you tried to do yeah
because it's just every informations
sent to North Korea they all write this
so we never write to them
so would you so would you have ever been
freed or was your prison sentence for
the rest of your life oh no I never
talked about that because it's in prison
I didn't met any lawyer you know that oh
so there's no trials you don't get told
anything you just get sent straight
directly and I didn't know that how many
years I studied in prisons oh wow okay
because it's all it could be with deaf
we could be just leave this present so
you know that when we stayed in prison
we walked in mountains yeah amarillos
but always work without the shoes
so tell me
how you got to the point where you
decided to escape again because this is
a point that I think is really amazing
is because everything you've just told
us on the journey so far is
I think it would be hard to keep hope or
even to keep trying
um is that you know the prison is you
know the eye almost dead you know to my
leg had problems yes tell us about that
was it was it a snake bite or an
infection no no that is it uh we always
walk in outside is without the shoes but
North Korea is not to Pavement you know
yes yeah so they the stones and the
glasses animal feed everywhere so we
didn't know the I didn't know the words
kind of inspiruses affected me but the
leg was swollen and the dark purpose so
your legs it just happens suddenly your
legs yes it had some kind of yeah yes
yes so I don't understand I just said
you know my cut off the my the process I
work because it's too tight yeah it's
too tight and the halfways I couldn't
failed so my head is I wanted to go
toilet but I already did it
halfways oh so so you couldn't feel
anything from your waist yeah yeah wow
so something serious had happened that's
a serious but they didn't give to me any
medicines so even though you you could
show that your leg was swollen purple
and you were saying you couldn't feel
anything yeah so what did they want you
to do just under you know the I the
state in prison is seven days but after
you know my head changed my scares
changed everything changed and then you
know the another person told me that or
your my body smell is it's a dead body
person's smell my God and so you were in
a room with other people yeah because
it's yellow it's a disgusting Waters
came out my purse yeah yeah okay came
out so
it is a horrible yeah of course but I
never give up I only is in prison when I
send back to North Korea ioni is my hope
my strength it starts one day I wanna
reunited my son that is only I remember
it so I never talked about it my
my situations I have to survive I've
already United my son my son is my last
family I never gave up I never give up
just only that this is survived me in
prison and then you know that they said
that you cannot tie the impression you
died outside anyway so they just kicked
me oh so they thought you were going to
die so they just released you from
prison yeah because I
also awful I'm so awful yeah
yeah with another uh girl it's the same
my ages she's married Jason's starvings
you know she always is shouting give me
more poor the poor food
so we release it together but she died
three days after so we were just outside
the prison and you had this terrible
infection and she died from malnutrition
yes yeah yeah so I just used to control
my mind control my mind I never put the
negative in here whole thing picture I
want to joined my son he growing up
universities you know everything is
healthy yeah so what can you do from
that point you've been kicked out of
prison they've essentially released you
because they think you're about to die
what how do you possibly planning an
escape from a country in that condition
but first two months I never thought
about that she said you know that I
accept North Korea because I couldn't
walk I couldn't walk
content is it summer you know some
container of the yellow is the
disgusting what is the camera or yeah
yes so I couldn't believe what I was
just to work in future or something
that's but two months after could be my
condition is a little bit better and
then I just try to think I want to
escape the North Korea again
but how no money my condition is about
and this system is changed not in 1998
2004 is a totally different changed
system
then I want to find out that is human
traffickers
so second time is myself human
trafficking to China wow so at this
point you allowed yourself to be human
trafficked because you needed to get
into China yes to eventually find a way
to be reunited I mean it's the sense of
that
yeah it's incredible because you'd been
trafficked once it was terrible and
awful and the the fact that you were
willing to allow it to happen again
because it would bring you one step
closer to finally getting to yourself
yeah so I never regret my choice yeah
because that is it could be close to my
son yeah yeah have to escape the country
North Korea first
so you get so you allowed yourself to be
trafficked across the border
and then take us through the next part
of your life there the next part when
you'd return to China with the human
traffickers
oh when I uh with the human traffickers
not so honing me these journey is
another uh goal you know the 20th score
and the old man because he's a human old
man too so it's not just women yeah it's
not just for sex trafficking it's any
people no that's man you should beat his
relatives but they paid money to broker
I see yeah so second time you know that
I saw that is North Korea the human
Tropicals walk human Tropicals work with
this Army so because it's a it's a I'm
military also not limited to put so they
just cross the border to US and on the
money so they work together
so they have the treatment Tropicals
work with this military soldiers and
then day nine times you know it's pretty
good to us and then we cross the border
so when we cross the border you know
everyone is going to speak Chinese so we
just walked in Mountain areas because
you know the we can't walk in the road
areas yes because people are looking for
you to report you to earn money and is
your leg still bad at this point I know
so you know that when I left North Korea
put the is it the plastic is my leg
and then I put this you know the song
It's a shoelace in here and after
wearing the shoes and the 10 children
put there so cross the river uh I didn't
took out my shoes I just said you know
it is was November you know ice is
almost this product so when you in in
water
this is your body so splitting but I
never care I never care if I didn't
cross this border I did make myself just
only thought about my son and you know
when I cross the border and walked in
Mountain areas I never sat down I knew
that is if I sat down then I couldn't
stand up oh God
still the pain it's still pain yeah and
did the traffickers know you're in this
no no were you hiding it from yeah I
hide everything oh do you think they
wouldn't have accepted you if you were
yeah because I told him he not allowed
me okay I see yeah so I everything is a
height everything is hide so then uh you
know the we arrived in India although
it's another Chinese local house so
this this is a long this is the pathways
so we have to that is on the taxi so
it's you know the Chinese taxi drivers
usually spy so it's a later time it's a
poor different people is on the taxi so
taxi drivers asked us a lot of questions
so they can't speak English they speak
Chinese so I only spoke Chinese and is
that because you learned from your
previous experience yeah yeah so I spoke
to him it's a that is my husband and you
know and the younger ladies of my sister
but she's mute and that is my father but
the day of growing up in Korean is
Village and they to this lack of
education so they can't speak Chinese
but that's true is many Chinese Korean
people speak Chinese not swear then he
asked me
but why you speak Chinese is really
weird so I said I graduated high school
and then he said that it's a late times
why all families move to Familia and
then you know the I just need to show to
him to Sony here you know that I walked
in mountains and the snake is a bite me
so now we went to the hospital so he
solved my lab so that time is it's dark
purpose so then oh I quickly you just
drive wow that's fast thinking yeah wow
yes so then we arrived the Chinese
broker house but after North Korean
broker is angry to me because I had a
lot of communications with the taxi
driver because he knew that is the time
system then I explained everything that
and after they laughing laughing
and everyone is shocking so you revealed
it yeah to the group they sold my love
why did you hide how did you walk
but you know when I sat down and then I
didn't understand all
I didn't stand up and after I told the
broker I had a child in here
I wanted to contact him but he said no
you already promised towards human
trafficking here
so next morning I woke up and then you
know the young ladies already gone
wow they've already been sold yeah
already sold
and then North Korean broker told me
that
I talked about it all right
because if last night on the taxi
you didn't speak Chinese could be we all
now is in prison but you saved my life
also you saved my family life in North
Korea so YouTube is contacted your son
so I have got only one number he's you
know that his smart his grandma's house
number and then I just is a quick
retired and I asked to her my son is in
there
so then my son is God is born but he did
the answer of poem and I contacted him
again and he off he hung up the phone
yeah and the third time
on phone and son is Mom
and he said Mom
and cried cried and then off
so long is the required and everyone is
heard myself cry
so that's at the moment is really silent
and then his man told me that
I didn't you
said salt human traffickings
you have to go you have to make yourself
because you saved my life
so today's I want to save your life
so I really thank you for this Tropicals
you know so he
believed that your actions in the taxi
had saved his life yeah and because of
that he wanted to save your life and he
released you from the human trafficking
contract
and encourage you to find your son did
you
you know that I wanted to immediately to
meet my son but you know that my
condition was
really bad could be my son was shocking
so you know that I stayed in my mother's
relatives house in China it's a two
months and then when I was in the comedy
and after are you like healed in that
period yeah yes yeah because it's the
relatives gave to me it's you know the
medicine okay yes and then I went to the
disability I didn't contact this to them
because I wanted I wanted to
my son I only need my son so I just hide
everything and then I went to the
disciplines so I saw that it's my son
alone in play in outside so I just
woke up him wow so you went in Disguise
you saw your son playing outside and you
walked up and you just grabbed him yeah
just grabbed him but you know the I was
another heartbreaking
my son was to look like that's a
homeless child yeah they never care
about my son 30 clothes and dirty hand
he also kind of managed Jesus his hunger
always because they didn't give to him
another is proper put because they hate
me or they hate my son because but he is
the grandchild yeah you know they never
care about her did he recognize you yes
yeah and did he want to go with you oh
of course yeah you know that I was a
first time it's a heartbreaking but when
I holding
he missed my his arms that is all over
the world is in my arm that is that's a
happiness moment I never forget I never
forget
and the thought standing there with him
with that moment it must have also been
frightening because if people had
arrived and seen you and recognized you
the farmer his mother the people around
that reported you before yeah you had to
get out of there quickly I guess yeah
immediately I just used to quickly and
then I went to the relative's house and
washed to him
and I gave to him beers
he's also hunger Hunger but you know
that I without to him the reasons that
is China is better than our school is a
lot of rice but they never gave to him
any prop food so after that he tired
tired because that is hungry people when
you eat
it's also heartbreak moment and then I
decided to touch I have to leave this
country because China is not the same
country if I repatriated to North Korea
I never see my son okay yeah yeah so how
did you get to the UK
I never talked about that is that I
wanted to call England I wanted to go
South Korea but our journey was failed
everybody is another race you know we
went to the qingdao but we didn't enter
this South Kore Embassy and the Sangha
is the same and then Beijing is true
because it's an important embassy's
Chinese police in there wow and they
take the ID card or possible wow okay we
had not and then we met tonight North
Korean refugees in front of the Beijing
Embassy and then we decided to that is
go to
ulambataro but we didn't know where is
but everyone is never give up because we
had no choice stayed in China we could
be sent back to North Korea or close the
water we could be success it is
so we went to the name [__] and across
the a Chinese border is really high
pencils strong fencer but to be close to
the Border but you know the I also find
out the Chinese police car came to me
but you know the another North Koreans
rescues to us then we arrived Mongolia
but we didn't find anybody and we stayed
in desert three days but of your son too
yes yeah then we had no rice and no
water and cold so bison is supposed to
dying so I had no choice my son could be
not died in this desert so we escaped
across the border again and in China
went to the China again
and I stayed in China two years you know
I selling these Korean dishes you know
something that and then I met is the
American pastor and he sent those United
Nations but I didn't know that that time
is United Nation what's Minister United
Nations what do they do so I talked
about there could be another Brokers one
of the Brokers so they could traffic you
again yes yeah yes so they told me that
is which country do you want to call
South Korea America or English European
countries so
South Korea America journey is still
dangerous and we don't we didn't know
that this journey is a success or not so
I chose the European countries the
reasons that could be I sent back to
North Korea risk is less than also all
Americans further away yes yes so I
arrived to England but I knew only
England I never heard the United Kingdom
or yeah England but after I was a daily
confusing you know some people told me
that welcome to United Kingdom or
welcome to Britain so oh that is right
to me they never landed me England oh I
see so you thought they just sent you to
a different place yes okay yeah where
you'd lived in your life up to that
point the kind of the North Korea and
the China and going to places like
desert and ulambatar very kind of rural
areas and what what year did you arrive
in England
I didn't know the much about the English
yeah what did you think when you arrived
what did you think what was your
impression
I only talked about it it could be safe
my family of course yeah because I only
doubt what the family is the first safe
family safe some places just only talked
about so England is successive to us but
that is we didn't know it's a safe or
not first time because I didn't know
any speak English words or so so I can't
eat everything and I never heard the
refugees or Aslam Seekers It's every
every word is on family language for me
of course you couldn't speak any English
then but when you arrived in the airport
or the first time which city did you
arrive in London oh yeah Heathrow
Airport yeah yeah did it look different
were you surprised by the city the
smells and oh that is a different you
know the when I arrived the Heathrow
Airport
I talked about the England only white
people yeah so but the airport is
different you know that I saw that's it
all world is all different people and
they're so surprised wow because in
China North Korea they allowed only
their people they never allowed the
foreign
and then you know I found that the
newspaper but everyone in support that
it's been oh my God it's another
shocking issue because in Korea you
weren't allowed to put the newspaper in
the bin I guess yeah of never never
thought if you just put the bin your
whole family is public executions or
send the political presence so we never
talked about that wow and I know that
you've to had a fantastic life
since arriving in England you've been
here a long time now you've had a second
child I believe
yeah I have now three children three
children wow and
um you told me as we were setting up
that you'd met the prime minister is
that correct oh yes yeah you know that
first time when I arrived in the UK I
didn't speak any englishes so it was
really difficult life for first times
but then I started learning my English
the reasons that my children growing up
they go to school and I wanted to
communication with my children so if I
don't know English it could be I lost my
family again so I really hard times it's
still the problems but learning English
and then I started my human rights
activities work the reason started by
all the sun asked me that when he was
12. Mommy why did you abandon me and
leave me but you know I never abandoned
my child I never leave my child I loved
him so that's why I survived to this Con
in prison but these questions changed my
life you know the many poisonous people
are needing my voice especially my child
so then I started my human rights work
and helping many refugees in in the UK
because deputies arrived in the UK they
can't speak English so I just opened
English class and
learning to English helping today's
social care not everything that and then
2020 when his copy that happened and
then you know there is in in a home I
always heard that many innocent people
died of this virus so I was really
shocking heartbreaking because already
experienced in North Korea at times I
didn't do anything but
in the UK's different different so I
wanted to I wanted to something so first
time is I wanna donations PP to Care
Homes because the tough times comes
really big daily yeah you know the walls
because it's all the people there so I
donations PP 7K homes in Manchester
areas and after they replied to us the
pgs arrived my country and the refugees
helped us so this message is changed my
second chapter UK in the UK also many
boys less people and somebody needs our
health then I stand off with local
elections because it's a local council
is not too multi-politics this is kind
of community community leaders helping
the people so I talked that okay I want
to leave payback because when I arrived
in the UK they will come to me and the
day helped me a lot of that so I want to
repay back these things to my local
people so I stand up it's a local
elections but I wasn't failed but that's
it that's also amazing experience yeah
so I never give up my politician life
too and you know last year's I met the
prime minister is and also this year to
his prime minister too and also the
Majesty King Charles 3 yeah yeah
this is you know that my life is every
time it's changed and growing off and
also I've read lots of history book you
know because I didn't know there is
Baltimore histories because North Korea
is always limited so I continued
learning my educations improved my
skills so I mean listening to your
storage units like it's genuinely
amazing and it's amazing to hear that
you you're such a you've got such a
strong mind like your focus from being
in all these places but being able to
push past the mental pain of losing your
brother the physical pain of having some
kind of horrific leg infection to get
back to your son and then to get to this
country and then to turn all of that
into a positive
for people who were in a similar
situation to you is so inspiring to hear
and I guess my final question that I
wanted to ask you is when you look back
on your life and all the unbelievable
experiences you've had
what do you think it's taught you what
something what's something that you've
learned from all of this
before I started my activities work
I was always
art and you know painful yet it's always
this kind of negative things from
imprompt me but after that I changed my
mind you know the my brother is courage
saved my life today my younger brother
College also saved today's my life and
my son without my son could be I have I
am not here so this is all people always
with me they give to me powers stand off
they will give up they gave to me always
these messages but nowadays many people
they can't listen to them so that is the
person I've learned that from another
people
so this is positive messages so we
always got positive messages from
another people but nowadays you know the
many people they come to Communications
each others so and also they can't close
to themselves
yes so if you don't trust to you you
don't trust another people you don't
trust another it's the person's respect
so that is I've all learned that so I am
really thankful my father my younger
brother and my son because
nowadays my strong that is the emotions
they all give to me
so I want to tell this word survivors
and the victims not weakness people we
are always strong and we teaching to you
what is freedoms and what is happiness
moment so we are not discriminating each
others we are human we are human
very inspiring message
um it's been fantastic to meet you and
it's a brilliant story and thank you so
much for sharing it with us thank you so
much thank you
we made a deal to each other that first
day
that no matter what happened we wouldn't
eat each other
because Robin of course was not a family
member
and we assured him that we would die
together he thought you might eat him he
thought we murdered him